[Musique]
et
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui je reçois une comédienne
élise à benicio qui appartient la troupe
où la compagnie comme on veut des
mauvais élèves en résidence à versailles
et nous avons le plaisir de la recevoir
pour la deuxième fois car ils sont à
nouveau à la fiche du mois molière
elisa benizio bonjour en genre merci
d'accepter cette invitation alors que
vous êtes sûrement pleine répétition
ben oui ça y est c'est la trêve 1 1 ça
rigole plus il est humain en est sur les
rails
très bien alors nous vous avez reçu il
ya deux ans avec antoine richard vous
êtes une troupe de quatre personnes déjà
on va dire ça wily a donc vous elisabeth
ioia bérénice koudria antoine richard
voilà on y voit tous les quatre
absolument magnifique et valérian béart
bonnet voilà donc on vous avait reçu au
moment de votre pièce les grands rôles
qui passait aux grosses écuries donc
lors du mois molière à versailles et je
vous propose qu'on au regard d'un co
extra afin de nous rafraîchir la mémoire
parlez moi d'amour du 12 octobre
c'est nous je souhaite aux formes roues
urbain
m
[Musique]
simo voilà on vous retrouve avec plaisir
ça c'est un spectacle qui a qui a très
bien marché qui a eu un succès énorme
dit moi en quelques mots l'histoire de
cette compagnie des mauvais élèves ou
après tant de phrase un peu frais 5e et
une compagne qui a huit ans d'existence
maintenant mais et avec laquelle on a
créé quatre spectacles
voilà très bien et vous êtes rencontrés
en majorité au cours jean laurent cochet
et vous êtes way et vous êtes en
résidence à versailles voilà alors là
qu'est ce qui va se passer c'est le
25ème édition du moment la 25e édition
du mois molière et vous avez deux dates
les 8 et 18 juin
voilà vous allez nous présenter un
nouveau spectacle
alors je vous laisse me raconter ce que
c'est ça s'appelle déjà comment alors
qu'isabelle les voisins et en fait c'est
pas vraiment un spectacle ses lectures
ma imaginé autour de d'extrait de pièce
d'un auteur contemporain qu'en fait
c'est pas vraiment le nouveau spectacle
des mauvais élèves c'est presque comme
une une une commande qu'on nous a fait
de créer quelque chose autour donc de
ses textes et on avait fait une première
représentation de cette lecture il ya
deux ans ou pendant le mois molière
aussi est donc là c'est voilà on réitère
l'expérience est facile dans les grandes
écuries les 8 et 18 hockey est elle hors
du coup pas ton monte enfin moi
j'entends lecture j'entends un petit peu
parfois ennuis
comment faites vous pour que drôle
effectivement le cancer
imaginez une forme un peu plus théâtral
avec un peu plus de costumes fin
d'accessoires
en lien ajouter des chansons aussi des
chansons françaises voilà en fait c'est
une lecture autour du thème des voisins
du voisinage des relations entre les
voisins on peut au centre résidence et
donc on m'a trouvé des chansons qui
ahronot ya trio voilà un peu autour de
l'écologie des voisins etc
il ya aussi une chanson de jean claude
thoret magnifique sur les voisins drôle
voilà donc c'est un peu théâtralisée
quand même pour rendre ça le plus
accessible et le plus divertissant
possible et vivant il vous vous comment
dire vous interpréter chacun un
personnage il ya des changements de
personnages étaient les changements de
costumes comme il y avait pour les
grands rôles
est-ce que ça n'était pas exacte ah oui
quand même vous avouer en fait on a
chacun je crois trois personnages donc
voilà il ya un peu ce côté ou encore une
fois nous ça nous amuse de passer d'un
personnage à l'autre
en fait on en dit lecture parce que
voilà on sera devant des pupitres et on
en lira même si on connaît quand même un
peu les textes montfort bah oui lève
mais voilà nous ce qui nous plaît c'est
aussi de passer d'un personnage à
l'autre donc on s'est imaginé quand même
des personnalités autour d'eux que c'est
de ces rôles quoi d'accord ok donc en
une heure où ça dure une heure à peu
près à vous m'aviez dit exactement
pourquoi la france pour sa dette à un
rythme frénétique alors bah oui msss à
alterne entre moment deux moments bleus
de parents j'ai ma machine à café qui
d'accord oui bah écoute on a de vous
voir alors du coup il y aura des
dispositions un peu différente qu'ovide
oblige proches pas si vous êtes au
courant
il ya donc une jauge il faut réserver on
paye un euro et je crois que si on ne
vient pas on paye 10 euros j'étais
content tu vois j'ai entendu dire ça bon
à vérifier en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il faut réserver donc les 8 et
18 juin après
on va aussi parler de bure votre autre
spectacle qui va se jouer dans les
yvelines aussi à bois d'arcy à bièvres
très prochainement
voilà comment ça lequel voilà enfin
klauk la vouvoie habillé en bur bon
spectacle et du oui pareil en a
plusieurs personnages mais sa c4 des
personnages présents dans et vous nous
en dire deux mots de ce spectacle les
yeux mais en fait c'est un peu le
spectacle qui a été inspiré par cette
lecture parce que c'est la journée des
voisins c'est à dire voilà sur l'estrade
verts vont défiler des voisins qui
viennent soit réglé leur compte soit
chanté une chanson soit voilà il ya un
grand buffet qui organisaient chacun
avançait la quiche lorraine est une des
cailloux ce titre parce que sinon c'est
trop fort et du coup règlement de
comptes gars c'est que ces 6 1 comment
dire une sorte de bilan annuel que font
ses habitants d'une résidence et ça a
commencé un peu la journée festive n'est
guère bon en même temps vient avec sa
personnalité et ses chaussettes
ces problèmes très bien dites moi vous
parlez de choses moins drôle alors le
confinement comment ça se passe pour une
jeune troupe comme la vôtre
qu'est ce que ça va être ta dû être très
dur bah c'était sympa mais comme pour
tout le monde mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas c'était pas facile surtout qu'en
plus nous pile au moment du confinement
n'avait une super belle tournée où on
allait voilà peu partout pour jouer nos
spectacles et puis on était aussi en
création à ce moment-là de bure donc
voila tout s'est un peu arrêté voilà
comme pour tout le monde oui mais mais
en même temps on n'a pas lâché
voilà on continuait à
faire avancer la compagnie les dates ont
pu être reportés on a quand même pu
créer un spectacle voilà maintenant on
prend les petits créneau les petites
fenêtres d'ouvertes eu recours au
pouvoir a pas d'accord et alors les
grands rôles vous jouez encore oui
immobilier est ce que vous avez dit
est-ce que vous avez suscité des
vocations ou des who éveillé un intérêt
pour le théâtre avec ce spectacle et
grands rôles qui quand même permet
vraiment de dés mais d'apprécier le
spectacle par dans le théâtre classique
pour ceux qui ne les met pas en quoi est
ce que vous avez eu des échos là dessus
mais j'en ai pas directement mais
j'espère en tout cas j'espère très fort
parce que c'est aussi un des des buts de
ce spectacle c'est de pouvoir donner
accès au théâtre classique et aux grands
textes
ouais et que jacques rivette rébarbatif
et qui par votre bouche la vôtre et
celle de vos trois comparses ne l'est
absolument pas et même très réjouissant
donc là on va vous retrouver en france
avec eux avec cette tournée
oui mais oui auparavant on a plusieurs
dates là au mois de juillet on a avec
nos trois spectacles on à châtel guyon
bat marseille on va voilà un peu partout
ce sera sur m
c'est sur votre site de la compagnie
d'accord quand vous dites trop spectacle
alors ya les grands rôles ya bure et
troisième est celui qui dès 2016 qui
s'appelle les amoureux de shakespeare
qu'on avait joué aussi en sécurité alors
naturellement d'autant que je devais qui
m'a échappé
bon bah écoutez très bien vous avez des
datas zinio comme on dit dans le métier
alors non justement cette année comment
savait pas vraiment commencé à l'espace
et pour avignon et que des festivals
qu'on
beaucoup nous ont contactés pour pour
jouer au mois de juillet mais a préféré
accepter
voilà deux parties sur les yeux et puis
autre chose quoi finalement à qu'on
connaît aussi très bien fait écouter un
grand merci déjà j'espère donc
j'encourage tout le monde allez vous
voir les 8 et 18 juin dans les grandes
écuries de versailles pour le mois
molière 25e édition
et puis vous avez d'autres projets
encore de création comment vous voyez
l'avenir je pense que le l'envié de
pouvoir jouer au maximum nos spectacles
vos créations ou la jouerie c'est encore
tout neuf très bien m'écouter
je souhaite vraiment beaucoup de succès
et je suis sûr mais pourquoi je
bafouille
je suis sûr qu un monde fou merci lisa
on embrasse vos comparses vos complices
bérénice coup dit antoine richard et
valérie imbert bonnet vous êtes toujours
mis en scène par shirley et dino
ils nous ont aidé et oui un peu moins
chaque fois que mon anglais publie ce
nom est plutôt qu'on voit là on essaye
de faire autre quand même vous
grandissez maintenant c'est bien ben là
bravo
bon je vous embrasse un grand merci et
l'isae puis à très vite sur scène avec
un grand plaisir hein
il
[Musique]